Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Durante il video si è sentito:
molti si sono messi a ridere.
Perché spesso, osservare quello
che fanno le persone, quello che provano,
è un'esperienza così forte
da portarci ad imitarli, o simularli,
o ci contagiano.
E ci si potrebbe chiedere se, però,
questo è qualcosa
che succede in casi speciali,
come quello che abbiamo visto,
oppure se piuttosto non sia la norma,
se di solito la psicologia degli altri
viene compresa tramite questi
meccanismi di imitazione.
E questa, in realtà,
è un'idea piuttosto antica.
Vedete qua dietro
alcuni filosofi, psicologi
che avevano sostenuto che la psicologia
è fatta prevalentemente di simulazione,
imitazione, empatia,
simpatia, contagio eccetera.
Però cosa ci dicono oggi, le neuroscienze?
La scoperta più interessante,
in questo ambito, è un po' paradossale
perché non nasce dallo studio
delle aree cognitive del cervello,
le aree del pensiero;
nasce dallo studio del sistema motorio.
Il sistema motorio
è quella parte del nostro cervello
che ci serve per muoverci.
È fatto di cellule
che, quando si attivano,
determinano il nostro movimento,
quindi ci fanno muovere.
E se vengono lesionate, tra l'altro,
hanno una serie di tragiche conseguenze
proprio nella produzione del movimento.
Tuttavia, c'è una piccola
popolazione di cellule
del sistema nervoso, del sistema motorio,
che sono diventate famose appunto
con il nome di "neuroni specchio",
che ha un comportamento un po' particolare
perché si attivano
quando noi ci muoviamo,
essendo appunto parte del sistema motorio,
però si attivano anche
quando noi stiamo con le mani in tasca
e vediamo qualcun altro
che esegue esattamente la stessa azione.
Quindi il pensionato
che sta con le mani in tasca,
e guarda gli operai,
in realtà sta lavorando
anche lui, potremmo dire.
E a che cosa servono queste cose qua?
Hanno una doppia funzione:
aprono in un certo senso
un canale bidirezionale
fra me e voi, tra voi e gli altri.
Perché replicare l'azione degli altri
da un lato serve per comprendere,
dall'altro serve anche per apprendere.
Quindi, da un lato serve
per leggere il vostro comportamento;
dall'altro serve per, invece,
mappare sul mio sistema motorio
quello che voi state facendo,
perfezionando i miei programmi motori.
Quindi una doppia funzione.
La prima ve la faccio vedere così,
facciamo una specie
di piccolo esperimento:
ora facciamo finta
che io vada a registrare
un singolo neurone mirror
della vostra testa.
Quindi voi tenete le mani
in tasca, non vi muovete,
perché sennò il sistema motorio
chiaramente si attiverà,
e osserveremo dei video,
quindi vedremo cosa fa
un singolo vostro neurone mirror
durante l'osservazione
di quattro scenette quotidiane.
Ascoltare un neurone
vuol dire ascoltare
la sua frequenza di scarica,
quindi sentirete uno scoppiettio:
tanto più scoppietta il video,
tanto più il vostro singolo
neurone mirror si sta attivando.
Quindi guardiamo il primo video.
Quindi una scena quotidiana, diciamo,
una persona che prende una cosa,
in questo caso una mela.
Voi avevate le mani in tasca:
il vostro sistema motorio
avrebbe dovuto rimanere silenzioso.
Invece una parte si è attivata,
e ha simulato esattamente
la stessa azione.
Questo neurone normalmente si attiverebbe
quando siete voi, a prendere la mela,
non quando soltanto guardate.
Poi, siccome sono molto specifici,
un'azione anche leggermente differente,
come questa, non funziona.
Quindi qui mancava la mela,
l'azione non era prendere la mela,
era qualcosa di diverso;
e quindi, quello specifico neurone mirror
in questo caso non si è attivato.
Altri sicuramente si saranno attivati:
ma non questo qui,
che era tarato sul prendere la mela.
Però la scoperta curiosa
è invece nel terzo video.
Guardate cosa succede.
Allora, cos'è successo?
Voi, con gli occhi, non avete visto
che la mela veniva presa;
però avete capito che, sicuramente,
là dentro qualcuno
stava prendendo una mela.
Il sistema motorio,
e in particolare il sistema mirror,
era avvertito della cosa;
quindi, se con le aree visive
non abbiamo visto
nessuna prensione di mele,
tuttavia noi abbiamo compreso
che là dietro avveniva
una prensione della mela in questione
e il sistema motorio
ha partecipato a questa comprensione.
E naturalmente, l'ultimo caso,
ovviamente, la mela non c'è
e l'attività del nostro neurone
è poco o nulla.
Quindi il sistema motorio
serve anche per capire
le azioni degli altri,
non solo per farci fare le nostre azioni.
E tra l'altro,
i deficit del sistema mirror
è stato dimostrato che portano
a un cattivo processamento
delle azioni degli altri.
Quindi capiamo un po' meno bene gli altri,
se abbiamo un deficit in questo sistema.
L'altra faccia della medaglia
era l'imitazione -
scusate, l'apprendimento:
serve per comprendere e per apprendere.
E apprendere per imitazione
è un fenomeno che non ha
bisogno di presentazioni.
Sappiamo tutti quant'è
importante, per apprendere,
da un lato, provare noi stessi,
dall'altro, vedere gli altri che lo fanno.
Allora è interessante...
Quest'immagine qua, tra l'altro,
è un'immagine di Meltzoff,
uno psicologo che negli anni '70
andava in giro per i reparti maternità
a fare la lingua ai neonati -
di benvenuto, presumo -
scoprendo però che i bambini,
già a poche ore dalla nascita,
saggiamente replicavano, rispondevano.
E quindi ha dimostrato, in realtà,
che già a poche ore
dalla nascita noi imitiamo,
siamo imitatori naturali.
Ora, naturalmente,
un bambino non ha ancora
uno sviluppo corticale,
e in particolare di quei sistemi inibitori
che bloccano questa imitazione.
Quindi noi riusciamo a bloccare,
se io faccio così -
adesso voi non mi state salutando,
però in realtà una parte -
tranne qualcuno -
però in realtà una parte
del vostro sistema motorio
stava esattamente facendo quello.
Bloccate l'azione,
l'azione non viene eseguita.
Però viene programmata, come nei bambini.
Quindi poi noi impariamo a bloccarlo,
ma questo comunque
ci porta a un apprendimento.
Quindi l'antico detto cinese
"Se ascolto dimentico,
se vedo ricordo, se faccio capisco"
in realtà è curioso,
perché spesso io "faccio"
anche quando, apparentemente,
non faccio ma guardo fare.
Appunto come il tizio davanti agli operai,
di cui si parlava prima.
Quindi serve per comprendere
e per apprendere.
Però uno potrebbe dire:
"Vabbè, ma in realtà questo riduce molto
l'idea di interazione sociale,
perché noi non ci limitiamo
a capire le azioni degli altri.
Noi dobbiamo capire le loro azioni
all'interno di un contesto emozionale,
sensazioni, gesti comunicativi,
linguaggio - quindi capiamo
tutte queste cose insieme."
Però la cosa interessante
negli ultimi anni, nelle neuroscienze,
è la scoperta che,
contrariamente a quello che vi ho detto,
i neuroni mirror non stanno solo
nel sistema motorio,
ma che l'architettura del cervello,
di tutto il cervello,
implica la localizzazione
di una moltitudine di meccanismi mirror
che stanno nelle aree motorie
replicando, e facendoci simulare,
le azioni degli altri,
nelle aree emozionali,
facendoci simulare o evocando in noi
le emozioni degli altri:
idem per le sensazioni,
i gesti, i linguaggi e così via.
Quindi, quando noi
interagiamo con gli altri,
in realtà tantissimi meccanismi
di imitazione e di simulazione
sono in atto in quel momento;
e ci portano, appunto,
a questo tipo di condivisione.
Un esempio su tutti può essere quello
legato all'area del cingolo.
Mentre le aree motorie
sono più o meno a quest'altezza,
quelle dei neuroni mirror,
classici del sistema motorio,
il cingolo è un'area profonda
che sta qua sotto,
nella corteccia prefrontale;
e fa cose differenti
da quelle delle aree motorie,
naturalmente, in parte sconosciute.
Si sa che il cingolo si attiva
quando noi, per esempio,
guardiamo fumetti divertenti,
comici, tipo questo:
"Non ci posso credere,
sta arrivando tua madre",
durante esperienze sensoriali piacevoli
come, per esempio,
cosa quanto mai quotidiana:
essere massaggiati da una Bond girl;
durante l'effetto placebo:
e poi, in questa sala,
si è attivato il cingolo
di tutti noi, poco fa,
durante l'osservazione del video
di Clinton e Eltsin
che nel '95 scoppiano a ridere
in conferenza stampa
perché il cingolo si attiva
anche quando noi osserviamo
espressioni positive, gente che ride.
Quindi abbiamo avuto tutti
una collegiale attivazione del cingolo,
poco fa.
Però qual è il filo conduttore
di tutte queste esperienze?
Per riuscire a scoprirlo,
ci siamo avvalsi di una collaborazione
per noi fondamentale
con l'ospedale Niguarda,
poco distante da qua, sta a Milano,
dove c'è il più importante centro europeo
di chirurgia dell'epilessia.
Per riuscire a mappare l'epilessia,
e a curare i pazienti,
questi medici localizzano
dei piccoli elettrodi
all'interno del cervello,
appunto a funzione di localizzazione
e mappaggio funzionale;
registrano dei pazienti,
e stimolano da questi elettrodi.
Il loro compito, naturalmente,
è quello di curare i pazienti;
e ci riescono in maniera eccellente.
Tuttavia raccolgono una quantità
di dati preziosissimi sul cervello umano,
che è altrimenti impossibile
riuscire a raccogliere.
Quindi tramite, questa collaborazione,
noi abbiamo cercato di capire cosa succede
quando, per esempio,
viene stimolata quest'area,
un'area che si attiva
quando noi osserviamo persone che ridono.
E ora ve lo faccio vedere.
Vedrete una paziente
con un elettrodo nel cingolo -
l'elettrodo naturalmente non lo vedete,
perché è dentro il cingolo -
la paziente tiene le mani alte,
le viene chiesto di leggere
e poi, a un certo punto,
il medico rilascia
una piccola stimolazione elettrica.
E questo è quello che succede.
[Video]
Quindi quell'area,
che poco fa noi abbiamo attivato
osservando Clinton e Eltsin
che scoppiavano a ridere,
non è un'area visiva;
le aree visive sono
da tutt'altra parte del cervello.
È un'area che, se stimolata,
produce risata.
Se qualcuno mette un elettrodo
in quest'area, ci fa ridere.
Quindi, l'osservazione di quella scena
si è direttamente mappata sulle aree
che controllano la nostra risata,
quindi ancora una volta un'imitazione;
però così forte da portarla
ad attivare, a farci ridere,
come se fosse una stimolazione elettrica
del nostro cingolo.
Per quello alcuni di noi
si sono messi a ridere,
durante quell'osservazione.
Quindi il meccanismo mirror funziona,
abbiamo detto, nelle aree motorie,
replicando le azioni;
ma per esempio, nel cingolo,
riproducendo e facendoci simulare
la risata e le espressioni
positive degli altri,
quindi un meccanismo complessivo.
Ora, per chiudere, a cosa serve,
o quali sono le possibili ricadute
di un meccanismo del genere?
Sono tantissime, ed è difficile
adesso riassumerle,
per cui lo farò così, in un attimo.
Non c'è dubbio che la scoperta
di questo meccanismo
abbia rivoluzionato
le neuroscienze cognitive,
questo è fuori discussione.
Idem per quello che riguarda
alcuni settori della filosofia:
abbiamo visto come alcuni filosofi
già sospettavano meccanismi simili,
quindi l'empatia eccetera.
I disturbi pervasivi dello sviluppo:
per esempio l'autismo ha,
tra i suoi tratti caratteristici,
il disturbo della sfera sociale.
Allora è chiaro
che un nesso potrebbe esserci.
E in effetti, molti studi stanno scoprendo
come i deficit di questo meccanismo
possano avere un impatto
tra i sintomi dell'autismo.
Addirittura la medicina riabilitativa:
ci sono alcuni studi che mostrano
come un paziente ortopedico immobilizzato
possa beneficiare se,
oltre alla pratica riabilitativa,
ha delle sessioni
di action observation therapy,
cioè osserva gesti eccetera.
C'è un guadagno.
Studi simili vengono fatti
addirittura sugli ictus,
dove la situazione
è senz'altro molto più complessa.
Psicoterapia, estetica,
psicologia dello sviluppo e apprendimento:
apprendere a usare uno strumento,
oppure apprendere le arti marziali
o qualunque altra abilità sportiva.
Tutto questo ha a che fare
con il meccanismo mirror.
Quindi, il futuro sarà divertente.
Arrivederci.
(Applausi)